[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره نقلت صحيفه
عن مسؤولينا ان مستشار الامن القوميه
الامريكيه جيكسوليفان اجرى محادثات سريه
مع كبار المساعديه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمر
بوتين في محاوله للحد من مخاطر نشوب
الصراع او ساعه حول اوكرانيا
للسلاح النوويه او البيولوجي
الروسيه
اقل من كيلو مترين عن مدينه
الوكاله صورا لعمليات ينفذها مسلحو بعض
واقل قائد ميداني في المجموعين قوته سيطرت
على بلدتين ملاسقتين للمدينه من جهه
الجنوب من الجيش الاوروبيه يحاول صدى حاجه
الا نايبو رئيس المجلس الاقليمي في خرسون
يوري ليفسكي ان القوات الروسيه لا تغادر
خيرسون في الوقت الحالي واعلنا نائب حاكم
مقاطعه خرسنال الروسيا كيريل ستريم ان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
حضر رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح
البرهانها تحاول الاختباء خلف الجيش من
اجل العوده الى الحياه السياسيه وطلب
البرهان حزب المؤتمر الوطني المنحل الحركه
الاسلاميه
بالحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه امين حسن عمر
جزيره ان فزاعه الانقلاب لم تعد تخيفه
احدا لان السودان لن ينجح فيهم الى دنيا
او بعثيون او شيعيون بحسب تعبيره واكد ان
ما سماه ايا انقلاب المدني تحت عنوان
تسويه ثنائيه مدعومه من الخارج لن ينجح
الا اذا هذه التسويه السواد الاعظم من
السودانيين
غادر الزعيم وحزبي انصاف المعارض عمران
خان المستشفى الى منزله في لاهور بعد
ثلاثه ايام من محاوله اغتياله ورحب عمران
بدعوه رئيس الحكومه شهباز الشريف لتشكيل
لجنه القضائيه للنظر في الحادثه لكنه
اشترت استقاله شريف نفسه ووزير الداخليه
وضابط في الاستخبارات كي تتمكن اللجنه من
العمل بشكل مستقل على حد قوله
يغضون ذلك تبحث الحكومه الباكستانيه في
الخيارات القانونيه الممكنه لمقاضات عمران
خان بسبب اتهامه مسؤولين كبار بالتخطيط
لاغتياله واعتقل سلطاته وعشرات من مؤيدي
عمران خان خلال مشاركتهم في وقفاتهم
تضامنيه
اشكركم على متابعات هذا الموجز قبل
اوقاتكم
[موسيقى]